- We're puttin' out real fire
and a lot of volume.
A shit load of volume of content.
This shit is intense, DRock, fuck.
(grooving music)
- What?
- [Gary] Seriously, outta real--
- If I'm really pissed off--
- Well, if I'm really pissed
off, I'd rather die than,
I would die.
But, let's do this--
- [Voiceover] Let's fight.
- Oh yeah, you did have a fight, right?
- Yo, DRock, can you not record this?
(laughter)
- None of this, none of this
is gonna be on the show.
(laughter)
I think you and I should get into a fight
and be on the same team
because we love each other,
we don't want to fight each other.
Let's go fight other people
and then assess each other in a fight
based on what we did against other people.
(laughter)
Kevin, that's a good idea, right?
- I think you guys should go jump somebody
for their Powerball tickets.
(laughter)
- Let's go walk to (bleep) two
buildings over and do like DM,
like, yo, who wants it!
- [Voiceover] He's a
gentle giant, that one.
- [Voiceover] Don't get
him really mad, though.
- Yeah.
(laughter)
- If he's really pissed
off he'll destroy--
- Are you guys still talking about me?
- [Gary] So cool.
- [Voiceover] It's crazy.
- Are you excited?
- I'm excited.
I'm like half nervous, half excited.
- I think you're gonna
do a really great job.
- [Voiceover] Awesome.
- Like, I'm really thankful you're here.
I think you've been
bringing a lot of value
and I'd love to hear how
it's going for you, so far.
- [Voiceover] Yeah, it's
just, it's a pleasure
having people that care about what you do
and have responsibility and
to feel like what you're doing
is noticed and actually matters, so,
that's, kind of--
- You're preaching.
- [Voiceover] I've
found it here in spades.
- How's it goin'?
- Good to see you, brother.
- Good to see you, too.
- Glad we could finally do this.
- (laughs) Yeah.
- [Gary] What can I
answer for you, if anything?
- I, so for me,
I think right now, my entire thing
is to learn as much as I can.
- Yeah.
- And that's what I want to do.
So, in terms of, like...
as someone that's just, what, six months
out of university.
- Yes.
- Who have met some
really interesting people,
what do you think I could be doing, um,
other than just trying to imitate,
or just picking up the good things?
- I think the number one thing
I would do if I were you,
knowing what I know, is...
becoming a practitioner,
and you don't have to be
a personal brand like me.
- Mm hmm.
- Creating something around an interest
like Music Head McGee,
or whatever, you know,
either a real you--
- Yeah.
- Or a thing.
- Mm hmm.
- Photography Boy 44, like
I don't care what it is.
- Right.
- But, becoming really great
at Snapchat, musically...
you know, like Dubsmash,
like all these things that are merging.
- [Interviewee] Yeah.
- Because they'll give you
a cadence and a skill set.
It's a preview.
Being good at Socialcam
helped me with Vine,
helped me with Instagram
video, helped me with Snapchat.
It's an evolution.
I always believe in creating your,
a competitive advantage for yourself
that experience...
doesn't allow.
So, there's people here that work seven,
10, 15 years, they have that advantage.
- [Interviewee] Right.
- What you could have the advantage
is capturing a voice
that doesn't exist yet.
- Right.
Yep, that makes valid sense.
- 'Kay.
- Cool.
- That's the tangible
black and white advice.
- Cool.
- Awesome.
- Thank you so much for your time.
Good to see ya again.
Talk to you soon.
- It's my effort to get in
every episode of DailyVee.
(laughter)
- You're just hacking DailyVee.
- (chuckles) Yeah.
- You don't even care.
- You gotta put my handle
in this time, Dan Grossman.
Although, I think, yeah, your followers,
anyway, I shouldn't have this on record.
- What? My followers are amazing.
This is entrepreneurship.
- You can't fake the musician,
you can fake the attitude.
- In entrepreneurship,
everybody in America,
everybody watching this right now,
it's the American thing to believe,
people don't think of
entrepreneurship as a skill.
- [Dan] Right.
- They don't think they can be LeBron
or be, you know, Nine
Inch Nails, or be 50 Cent.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- But everybody looks at
me and says I can do that.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- They don't understand
that it's a talent.
By the way--
- [Dan] Yeah?
- The other thing that's,
it's more practical to
actually recognize I'm a talent
and let's say they think
I'm a hunter, I'm the best.
- Yeah.
- Them being a 68
is actually, quite financially
and happiness worthy,
whereas you look at LeBron and he's 100,
being a 68 means that, like,
you'll spend a lot of time
in rec leagues, like,
like, there's a different, right--
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- It costs you money...
- Mm hmm.
- To try to be a 68 musician.
You paid 15,000 demo.
You have overhead, like,
you can't pay rent.
- [Dan] Yeah, yeah.
- This thing, being a 60,
even for the people that are clearly,
understand that they're
not me, talentwise...
- [Dan] Yeah.
- It's actually quite practical
to be a 68.
- [Dan] Yeah.
- That's where it's interesting.
- [Dan] Right, right.
- Yeah.
- [Dan] 'Cause you could start
something shitty--
- [Voiceover] You're back in
your office when you're done.
- I gotta go.
- [Dan] Okay, real quick.
- Andy, pull up the,
the secret share.
A lot of you don't know about this, yet.
I haven't really promoted it.
Entrepreneur Answered on YouTube.
What's the unique URL?
- [Andy] Entrepreneurship Answered.
- What's up?
- So, YouTube, same as we're always doing.
I have it broken out.
We're gonna see how it performs.
- Mm hmm.
- So, retargeting, subs, people
that've watched your videos,
people in your atmosphere.
- This is my monthly field?
What do you think?
Think it's an over-allocation to that?
- [Andy] For the podcast?
- Mm hmm.
What's your gut tell you on that?
I feel like the podcast,
because it's energy...
can never really win, 'cause it's not,
it's a podcast that's auto of a video--
- Yeah, of course, like if we were--
- If I made a podcast, if
I actually did a podcast,
we'd win.
You know what we need to talk about?
You know what, Staphon?
Real quick, help me think about this.
I have a very interesting thing
that I've never talked about.
But, I've posted the Instagram photo
and it always fucks with everybody,
which is basically my core
college friends were black kids.
- [Staphon] Yeah.
(laughter)
- Which I--
- [Staphon] When I first saw it--
- And it's very interesting because
I didn't go into like hip hop music,
like I don't play in an
African American minority world
in my career.
As a matter of fact, if anything,
tech investing forced me
deeper into old white dude
than I'd ever been, right?
'Cause at least, like our
business had to have some...
I need to find, you know,
I do not like, even though I, like,
the furthest I go into like
sexism and things of that nature
is like, I'm girly, I'm empathetic.
- Yeah.
- Which is true and it's
why I think I'm good at,
by the way, that's why I
think I'm good at that.
- Yeah.
- Like, I actually just think I'm a girl.
- Okay.
- I know it's weird.
But, you know, like I feel, um--
- [DRock] Well, you're emotional.
- That's not an inherently
female characteristic.
- Is it not?
- No.
- Great, see, exactly.
- So, like, I don't know,
here's what I know.
I know that I'm motherly.
I know that I like having this
because I'm like I'm gonna
take care of you guys.
- Right.
- Like, I know that,
I know, the reason I get mad at everybody
is they don't realize,
my 51/49 probably has a lot more to do with
my own ego slash motherly thing.
It's not even ego, like
I saying that as a hedge.
It's 'cause I like it.
I genuinely believe that I can do,
that's where I think it's ego.
- [India] Yeah.
- Like, I genuinely
believe, under my watch,
you can win more, right?
And then, what I may wanna
do for #AskGaryVee, and I'm not kidding,
let's see how fast I can do this,
we may answer one question, one,
and then I want you to run all the b-roll
of everything that you just had,
play music over it and
be like, this is why
there wasn't a GaryVee,
a #AskGaryVee today,
this is what happened
during that time slot.
Could be kinda cool, just
see what everybody does.
Yeah, could be kind of,
just mixing me it up a little.
Alright, let's do the barter
videos, what are they?
(busy chatter)
The thing that I think will stun you,
or make you triple reaffirm
how good this place is,
is the intent is always right.
You could be upset because
you think I'm stupid
and I'm wrong,
but that's a very different
thing than the intent.
And I think if I can drill that home,
we can build something very special.
So, that's my ambition,
and I really, really have no
idea if I can pull it off.
Eight years ago when
you read a Yelp review.
(door knocking)
- [Voiceover] Tony Robbins.
- Fuck.
(laughter)
- Where else are you gonna hear that?
Oh, you got a call, Tony, sorry.
(laughter)
- Can you just tell him
fivey, five minutes,
some how, some way?
So, next time this is on the calendar
come with your best questions.
Have a great day, guys, thank you.
Tony, it's Gary Vaynerchuk, how are you?
So, obviously, you know, you and I
have these great feelings
towards each other,
but obviously we're not
talking everyday, but
I think you're gonna be
effected by what I have to say,
which is, I believe that
Snapchat is going through
a very similar, uh,
Twitter 2007, YouTube 2006
kind of moment, and I personally believe
that you could be very
dominant on the platform
and it could be a benefit for you
and the things that you wanna
communicate to the world.
Whereas, both you and I
have very large followings
on Twitter and other platforms.
It doesn't matter how many
people you can potentially reach,
it matters how many people
you actually reach, right?
When I think about your world, Jesus,
now I see a world where
you're about to board a plane
or you're going to the
bathroom or you're like
in between meetings,
you take out your phone,
you say guys, this is what
you need to be thinking about,
you make two or three 10 second videos,
it's a 30 second rant, and
millions of people consume it.
Alright, man, take care.
Bye-bye.
(grooving music)
(laughter)
You're far better off
ROI to schedule a one minute meeting
than take the two minutes
to write that email,
'cause it's 94.7% chance
that I'm gonna look at it
and be like, oh, there's a lot there,
I'm not gonna read this.
(laughter)
I'd rather talk to him.
Just, FYI.
- No, that's good to know.
- What word count do you hit?
- [Gary] Anything--
- Over like 10?
- [Michael] Two sentences.
- Anything that is in
the body of the email--
- [Jeff] Right.
- Is a problem.
So, put everything in the title.
How great is it?
- [Jeff] Yeah.
- The title game's the game.
Guys, send emails fully
in the title, it works.
- [Jeff] It does work.
- It's respecting the other person's time.
- So, basically--
- What do you think about that, DRock?
You think I should do more of like the,
kind of like those TV
shows that look like,
I don't do that a whole lot.
- [Jeff] Like an infomercial?
- [Michael] Break the third wall?
- [Gary] Yeah, the third wall, exactly.
That'd do a much better job.
Did you see what just happened?
- That was pretty good.
- You called it an
infomercial, which it wasn't,
he called it breaking the
third wall, which is exactly
what it was.
(laughter)
I was just like, DRock,
do the first edit of DailyVee,
can you just give a, could you give a one
(bell dings)
to Engert
and a zero to Nicholson?
(bell dings)
Nicholson's back on a losing streak.
- I'm at negative two.
- Lost at the Celtics game last night.
- [Jeff] Brutal.
- Alright, so what do we got?
(office chatter)
- Is this okay with that?
- Yeah, I'm good.
- Did Minnie get you, Tina?
(relaxed music)
I had a feeling Jeff's
gonna be the best story.
(laughter)
He was so pumped.
- At...
KP, you could see you
stand up and go like this.
- [Matt] Yeah, you got him good.
- It was like a split
second, but you could,
somebody stands up in a
black sweater and was like
(cheers gently) you could tell it was you.
- I went crazy.
It's the craziest.
(laughter)
There's nothing like it in sports.
Courtside?
I'm as close to you, right now, as I am
to like the players.
- [Matt] Yeah,
the foul was in your lap.
- Oh, yeah, like--
- Probably hit your foot.
- It was you and Zinger together,
yelling at the ref.
(laughter)
- It's so bonkers.
- [Voiceover] They're so big.
- They're so big.
- [Voiceover] You have my number, right?
- I think if I was that
big I would beat up DeMayo.
(cackling)
I love you.
I invested in Medium, and
Product Hunt, and Luxe Valet,
and a lot of good bets
that need time to play out,
that's how we got here.
- [Voiceover] Very cool.
- Terry?
Hey, it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
just tryin' to get a hold of you.
I'm in tight meetings
here, but I'd love to
help out if I can.
I'm gonna try one more number,
if I can't make that
then I'm gonna have to go
to this other meeting, and then
we'll try later if that still works
for your deadline, but I
have empathy that it may not.
Have a great day.
It's gonna have to be
rescheduled, or not happen.
It's okay.
It happens, good effort.
- I think--
- Good effort.
Yo!
- Hey, Gary!
- [Gary] How are ya?
- Good to meet you, man.
- Dave.
- Dave, how are ya?
- What's up, brother?
- [Gary] 'Sup big dog?
- Good to see ya.
^ - Good to see ya, too, man.
- I'm Vaughn.
- Such a pleasure.
Al Toon, Wisconsin's jersey?
I love it, man.
- [Andy] You might have it--
- I don't have it.
- [Andy] Alright.
- I love it, thank you.
- I figured you had that.
- I love Al Toon.
This is great.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- DeMayo, we need to frame this one.
We need to frame it.
Can you
put a note for him?
Thanks, Ox.
- [Andy] Cool, brother.
- [Gary] Thank you so
much, that's really nice.
- I was tryin' to hit
'im, I figured you got--
- [Gary] You're hittin'
the emotional center.
Uh oh.
Uh oh, what is going on here?
You're about to find out.
There's a lot going on here.
- [Andy] Yeah, no kidding.
- There's a lot going on, here.
(lively music)
This whole thesis, like this whole game,
like this whole everything,
the reason I think I invented,
as a young kid, I want
to buy the New York Jets,
it seemed like a big enough goal
that would take me a long enough time
to make what I really love
about entrepreneurship,
which is, I love the process.
I'm here because I love the game.
- [Andy] Right.
- You know the athlete that retires at 37?
They've been washed up for
four years, but they just know
that the last time they
take a snap, that's it.
Do you know how thankful I
am that I'm an entrepreneur
and businessman, that
our game lasts forever
until I take my last breath?
I love the process, as a matter of fact,
if you wanna get really deep and weird,
I want people to understand that
at its purest form, intent is
the only thing that matters.
The reason I'm not scared of anything
is I know where my intent is.
I knew that if I wrote Crush It!,
I knew that an unbelievable
amount of people
were gonna make millions
of dollars if they read it.
I mean, it basically predicted
everything that happened
seven years ago.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Right?
And I knew that it cost $13.
I wasn't selling some
be in my mastermind--
- [Andy] Course.
- For 50,000 a month,
and I'm gonna just tell you
enough that you'd never,
I literally obsessed with
putting myself out of business.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- I wanna give people the tools.
I have no interest in,
I make a book every two years for,
I have a, #AskGaryVee's coming.
It's, I don't know, 12, $19, $17!
I put out fucking #AskGaryVee
show every fuckin' minute.
Like, this all comes
out of me gettin' mine.
- [Andy] Yeah.
- And, and, and so, what I'm excited about
is I think I'm playing it so
differently than everybody else
that looks like me.
There's a big difference
between becoming rich
and becoming wealthy,
and its predicated on talent,
but another weird little thing,
it's called fucking patience.
The other thing that I'm
sure you get a lot of,
and I'm getting bombarded on Snapchat,
every goddamn Snapchat
thing, now, is like,
Gary, how do I immediately get X?
- Dude, it's,
it's the number one thing.
How do I become a millionaire this year?
- [Gary] Right.
- [Andy] You know, I'm like--
- I'm always like, would you
rather become a millionaire
period?
- [Andy] Yeah.
- Or not at all?
Intent is not being talked about enough.
Listen, actions are greater than words,
but before you get into actions,
they often times, not always, are mapping
to your intent and I just
think it's people's North Star,
it's their religion, it's their thing.
I'm always comfortable in my skin
because I know what my intent is
and if I mess up then I'll say I'm sorry,
but it's real exciting to
know that it didn't start
or come from a bad place.
Makes me, it puts me at peace
and it puts me at peace as a professional,
and it puts me at peace as a human being.
(lively chatter)
And I think the world needs more people.
And by the way, everybody
does it different,
everybody's got different skills.
- [Voiceover] Of course!
- And the truth is, I'm worried about,
sometimes if you think
that I did something
and then you start
digging and you're like,
didn't do it the right way.
- [Voiceover] Didn't do it the right way.
- So, that's not interesting.
- [Voiceover] Right.
- But I felt, through our
call, that you were that,
I mean look, the answer is,
in the same reason
you're a good sales guy,
same reason you're
sitting here and smiling
and all that good energy.
- [Voiceover] Yeah.
- You're gonna win.
- [Voiceover] Oh, all day.
- When you grow up a huge sports fan,
the thought of, like,
the thought of having,
even though I dreamed to
own the Jets, it's funny,
I dreamed this big ambition,
but I didn't realize how
wealthy I'd have to be
along the way to actually pull it off.
So, some weird, like,
I thought it was more real
that I would buy the Jets
than have Knicks courtside
seats because I was so,
I only think about that.
I didn't care about all the other stuff.
So, in a weird way, I'm like...
thank you.
In a weird way, like,
that's incredible for me.
I think they're the
biggest tickets in sports.
Like, there's nothing like it.
And then, all the things
I didn't think about,
which is like,
Ice Cube sitting two seats from you,
you know, like, or,
or, the way my career's played out.
I'm friendly with Carmelo,
so him coming over
and giving me dats,
or, or,
like yesterday, there
was a foul right by me
and its me and Porzingis
on TV yelling at the ref.
(chuckling)
- [Voiceover] That's awesome.
- And all my friends
texting me, like what?
(chatter)
- [Gary] Yeah, that free corner foul?
I jumped up, like I'm in the screen.
DailyVee 005 is here, I just
put it up on Instagram.
Check it.
I'm Gary V-E-E on Instagram, too.
Really good day, today.
- [Voiceover] Beautiful day, no?
- Yeah, great day.
So, just wishing you all a great night,
and, or, actually, probably, great day,
but anyway.